What has happened in Chemistry is that
there has been this inertia
of people doing chemistry
the same way for hundreds of years
because
it's - this is a model of apprenticeship,
the advisor tells us you know, how to do things.
The student doesn't really question
if that's the right way
of doing it or not.
So what we're doing in this program is saying
well, wait a second,
do you mean the 4th Industrial
Revolution?
We have all these new tools
especially artificial
intelligence and robotics
that can transform
the way we do science.
So functionally we are
going to change the
scientific discovery process
you know?
This is not about the simple hypothesis
driven research,
loops of iteration.
It's about fundamentally challenging
how we go about the scientific
discovery process
in chemical space.
It is believed that you know, developing a
new material takes about $10 million in 10 years
roughly, order of magnitude right?
It is because all this chemistry is done by
hand and is done in a very time inefficient fashion.
Several layers of science have been transformed
by the use of machinery.
The focus of what we're talking here is really
building out the tools, platforms, and methods
of how we go into chemical discovery, but
that’s the thing, chemistry sits as a central
science to almost anything; health, materials,
energy, so we're talking about not only changing
how one goes and does discovery in chemical
science, but the feedback, the spill off from
that means we can affect things like energy
storage, energy conversion from solar, new
pharmaceutical drugs, new textiles.
One of the things that we want is that any
educated or trained person that has a molecular
dream, that imagines a potential solution
to a problem in the world has easy access
to a machine that we could call it like a
molecular maker lab that you write what molecule
you want and it will tell you what are the
reagents that you need, it will put them together,
make small quantities of this material and
then go and test it.
You know, people new to the CIFAR program
don't really know what to make of it, you know,
it's the first time they've heard of it.
The thing that's enabling about this is it's
allowing us to break down borders and really
put many different people in the same room
and giving them free reign to discuss.
You know, this is giving people the opportunity
to make these sort of connections, long-standing
connections and also again it provides a flag
for people to rally around that we are CIFAR fellows.
[Music]